The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: I want to remind
and clarify as needed the
equilibrium constant Kp for
gas phase reaction was the
ratios of the partial pressures
referenced to some
reference pressure, which we
usually take as one, one bar.
To the stoichiometry , pD
divided by p naught, to the mu
D where species C and
D are products.
And the reactants are
on the bottom.
And usually we don't write p
naught, but it's important to
remember that it's there.
And then we can also write this
in terms of the Gibbs
free energy for the reaction.
The standard Gibbs free energy,
minus delta G naught
of the reaction,
divided by RT.
And what this tells us is
that this is a number.
This is a number, there's
no pre-factor
here that has units.
That's a unitless number.
And it doesn't depend on
the total pressure.
And the other thing to remember
is that delta G
naught for the reaction is
the process of taking the
reactants separated in separate
boxes, separate
containers, and the final
product, the final step, is
the products separated in
individual containers.
That's what we write when
we write delta G
naught for the reaction.
We also looked at K in terms
of mole fractions.
So if you replace all the
partial pressures with the
mole fraction times the total
pressure, you get an
expression for K sub x, which we
define as the mole fraction
of the products to the
stoichiometric powers.
Which is also unitless.
This is true, it's unitless.
But, if you write it in terms of
K sub p, the total pressure
comes in here. p total, divided
by the reference
pressure to the minus delta nu,
where this is the change
in the number of moles,
in going from
reactants to products.
And there's K sub
p sitting here.
So unlike K sub p, which doesn't
depend on the total
pressure, K sub x does depend on
the total pressure through
this term right here.
So when we look at problems
where we change the pressure,
the total pressure of
the system, this is
going to stay the same.
Because it only cares
about delta G
naught for the reaction.
But this K sub x will depend
on the total pressure.
And that's often a source of
confusion in doing problems.
OK, any questions?
We're going to do an example
where we change
the pressure first.
So there are examples in the
notes, and I'm going to skip
the first one.
I'm going to go to the second
one, which is the effect of
the total pressure
on the reaction.
And Le Chatelier's principle,
for pressure.
And the example we're going to
take is a fairly standard
example, also.
Which is the reaction of N2O4,
which is a gas, to 2 NO2,
which is a gas, the kind of
reaction that happens when you
have smog and, fairly common
in big cities.
The question we're going to ask
is, what happens when we
change the total pressure
in this reaction here.
Which way does the
equilibrium go?
Does it go to the right,
does it go to the left?
Does it go to the products
or the reactants.
And so, in order to answer that
question, we're going to
ask a slightly different
question.
We're going to ask what is the
molar ratio, what is the
fraction, what is fraction
of the reactant,
the N2O4 that's reacted.
That has reacted.
And we're going to
call that alpha.
It's the number of moles that
have reacted divided by number
of moles initially.
So we're going to need to find
at equilibrium what is the
number of moles of N2O4
that has reacted.
So we have to set
up the problem.
And so the way that, the
standard way of setting up the
problem is to write the
equilibrium, 2 NO2 gas.
And then on this line here, we
write the initial conditions
before we set up the
equilibrium.
And let's say that we
have n moles of N2O4
initially in the box.
And zero moles of the NO2.
So we have n moles here.
And zero moles here.
At equilibrium, let's write
the number of moles.
A certain number of moles of
N2O4 will have reacted, let's
call that x.
So n minus x moles left.
For every x moles of N2O4 that's
reacted, we create two
moles of NO2.
So we have 2x here.
And then we're going to need
the total number of moles,
because we're going
to be doing mole
ratios, mole fractions.
So the total number of moles
at any time is the sum of
these two, n minus x plus 2x.
It's n plus x.
So if we're going to be writing
our equilibrium
constant in terms of mole
fractions, we're going to need
mole fractions.
So the mole fraction at any time
is n minus x divided by
the total number of moles,
which we just
calculated as n plus x.
And this is 2x divided by
the total number of
moles, n plus x.
And what we want is
this ratio here.
We want the ratio of the number
of moles reacted, which
is x, that's the number
of moles that's gone.
That have reacted.
Divided by the number of moles
initially, which is n.
That's what we want.
We want to see how that is going
to change with pressure.
So we're going to deal first
with Kp, because Kp doesn't
depend on total pressure.
We're going to write
that down.
Then we're going to
go to Kx, somehow.
And that's going to depend
on pressure.
So let's see what Kp is here.
So K sub p, you've got
the products on top.
So it's the partial pressure
of NO2 to the second power,
divided by the partial
pressure of
N2O4 to the one power.
And everything is referenced
to one bar,
everything's in bar.
And in terms of the molar
fractions, it's the total
pressure squared, times the mole
fraction of NO2 squared,
divided by the total pressure
to the first power.
So the square root on
top gets divided by
one factor of pressure.
So we have total pressure
in front.
Divided by x to the N2O4,
and that's p times Kx.
So let's plug in what these mole
fractions are from our
table here.
The mole fraction of NO2 is
2x divided by n plus x.
2x divided by n plus x
to the square power.
Mole fraction of N2O4, n minus
x over n plus x. n minus x
over n plus x.
Multiply, square the
top, 4x squared.
Divided by n plus x squared.
Things sort of cancel out here.
Rearrange.
4x squared divided by n squared
minus x squared.
What we're really interested
in is, we're not
interested in x.
We're interested in
x divided by n.
So let's divide both the top and
the bottom by n squared.
And we're going to get
alpha come up.
So this is then p times 4 alpha
squared divided by one
minus alpha squared.
This is not, there's no
total pressure here.
The only way, the only place,
where the total pressure comes
in, is right here.
This is just a number that
doesn't care what the total
pressure is.
Which is why we're using it.
And not K sub x, which cares
what the total pressure is.
So now we can solve for alpha.
We can solve for alpha by
rearranging this equation.
This is just a number.
And this is where the total
pressure comes in.
So you rearrange that, and you
get alpha is equal to 1 plus
4p divided by Kp, to the
minus 1/2 power.
And if I rewrite that slightly
to make it a little bit easier
to see what's going to happen,
when I change the pressure, 1
plus 4p divided by Kp,
to the 1/2 power.
And that's what I'm after.
This tells me what happens at
equilibrium to the amount of
NO2 as I change the
total pressure.
This is the only place
where it comes in.
So now I can see that if I
raise the pressure in my
container, raise the pressure,
this is in the denominator, so
this fraction gets smaller.
Alpha gets smaller.
I raise the pressure, the
fraction of material that
reacts gets smaller.
Therefore, the reaction goes
towards the reactants.
If I decrease the pressure, this
is a smaller number here.
The fraction gets bigger.
Alpha goes up.
If I decrease the pressure and
I compare what happens to the
number of moles of reactants
that react, more of it reacts.
Equilibrium shifts towards
the product.
And this is Le Chatelier
that you already know.
Le Chatelier's principle,
for pressure.
The way it works is that Le
Chatelier's principle states
that, this chemical system wants
to stay as close to what
it was before.
It doesn't like change.
It doesn't want to have
any change happen.
So if you increase the pressure,
the chemical system
says, hey, you know I'm not so
happy that you're increasing
the pressure on me.
I'd like to go back to
a smaller pressure.
It doesn't like change.
Very conservative.
And the way to decrease the
pressure is to decrease the
number of moles in
the container.
How does it decrease the
number of moles?
Goes back to where there
are fewer moles.
And that's on the
reactant side.
How many of you know
Lenz's law?
In magnetism.
The diamagnetic materials.
Right.
At least one person knows it.
It's the same idea.
You take a diamagnetic material
in the absence of a
magnetic field, and you slowly
move it into a place where
there's high magnetic field,
what does the diamagnetic
material do?
It orients its magnetic moment
to reverse the field.
So that there's no
field inside.
It starts out with no field.
Doesn't like change.
So Lenz's law says it's going to
do whatever it can so that
it retains no field inside.
Le Chatelier's principle is
basically the same thing.
Equilibrium systems are
very unhappy if you
try to change them.
And that's what happens for Le
Chatelier here with pressure.
Any questions?
So before we go to Le
Chatelier's with temperature,
and the van 't Hoff equation.
Let's do a little detour here
and talk about equilibrium in
solution, which is really as
important, or if not important
for a lot of you, then gas
phase equilibrium.
Although gas phase equilibrium
was where everything started.
And still a huge deal.
OK, so in equilibrium now, when
we talk about equilibrium
in solution, we still have
to, still going to be
the chemical potential.
It's still going to be looking
at how chemical potential
likes to go downhill.
And we're going to have to write
chemical potential for a
species, A, let's say,
which is in solution.
At some concentration
c sub A in solution.
And the concentration could be
given in moles per liter.
Or it could be in
grams per liter.
Or it could be in grams
per 1000 grams.
Whatever your favorite unit
of concentration is.
Use it.
Stick to it.
And in order to do equilibrium,
we're going to
have to reference it to, so this
would be the species at
some arbitrary concentration.
We're going to have to reference
it to some reference
concentration.
Just like we referenced
everything to one bar before,
as our standard pressure.
And we're going to take, usually
you take one mole per
liter, or one gram per liter,
or one whatever.
One as your reference
concentration.
And the reference concentration
is going to
disappear from the equation.
It's just like the reference
pressure.
Disappear from the equation.
So we're going to reference this
to some standard state
chemical potential.
Where the naught refers now to
the standard concentration.
And instead of having RT
log p, now we're going
to have RT log cA.
It's kind of like considering
the molecules in the solution
to act like an ideal gas.
Knowing fully well that behind,
that underneath the
cA, is this reference
concentration of one.
One whatever is your
favorite units.
Now, it's a little bit
more complicated than
for the ideal gas.
Because your solution may
contain other things than your
reactants and your products.
Especially if you're
doing biology.
It could be a buffer.
It could be a buffer,
it could have salt.
It could have a pH that's not
equal to seven, whatever.
And so this reference, chemical
potential, now needs
to be referenced to a particular
pH or salt
concentration.
Or whatever the properties
of your solvent are.
Or your solution are.
And that's the big difference.
In an ideal gas, it's
reference to vacuum, basically.
There's nothing there.
In here, in solution you have
all these molecules of
solvent, molecules of salt,
molecules of acid, or
whatever, that are going to be
around to buffer the pH.
And that's going to change what
the chemical potential of
a species is.
And if I change the pH and I've
got a molecule that I'm
interested in, it may not have
an acidic moiety on it, but it
could still care what
the pH is, slightly.
And that would change what the
reference potential is,
chemical potential is.
So this is really important
to remember.
And there are textbooks that are
written on how to do this
the right way.
We're not going to
do that here.
We're just going to remember
this is, we're going to assume
that this is done correctly.
Once you take that as a given,
that you have a way to have a
reference chemical potential
at a properly referenced pH
and salt concentration, then
you can go through the same
analysis that we went to
for partial pressures.
This looks just like the ideal
gas, where the concentration
replaces the partial pressure.
Or the pressure of chemical A.
And you can go through, then
the same argument, where
you take your reaction.
And you initially have some
delta G for the reactants.
And you have some delta
G for the products.
And the difference is the delta
G for the reaction,
delta G naught for the reaction,
and then on this
side here, you have a solution
of A, so the reaction would be
nu A times A, which
is in a solution.
Temperature and pressure.
Plus nu B of reactant
B, in a solution,
temperature and pressure.
Going to a nu C, C solution,
temperature and pressure plus
nu D, D in a solution, constant
temperature and pressure.
So this is taking a solution
of A, in one container, a
solution of B in another
the container.
That's the initial point.
Mix them together.
Let them react.
Then you take the product,
you put them in separate
containers.
And that gets you the stuff that
you have the reaction.
So when you mix A and B, you're
going to have the same
entropy of mixing.
You're going to lower the delta
G. Of the solution.
And you're going to have
the same curve that
goes down like this.
To the mixture of products.
And just like for the gases,
where we wanted to know what
is the bottom of this curve
which gives us the
equilibrium, we can
do the same thing.
Exactly the same thing,
for solutions.
And so we start out with a
mixture of the A and B in
solution and C and D, reactants
and products together.
And we let the reaction
proceed a little bit.
And we look at the change in
delta G, going from, say this
point here through
that point here.
This will be delta
G of epsilon.
We ask, is this positive,
negative, or zero.
And if it's zero, that means
that we're in equilibrium,
that we're actually
sitting down here.
And that gives us the
equilibrium constant.
So, just for the sake of
completeness, let me just
write down what we would do.
We would react it for
a small amount.
And then we'd end
up with nu C.
So you would have the chemical
potentials of the products
minus the chemical potentials
of the reactants, nu C mu C,
plus nu D mu D, minus nu A mu
A, minus nu B mu B. And
instead of these chemical
potentials, you would write
them in terms of the pure
chemical potentials times
their concentrations.
And then you'd end up with
epsilon times delta G naught
of the reaction, plus RT log,
and then the concentrations.
And then you write them
in a different way.
So if it's moles per liter, you
usually write that with
these brackets here.
That means concentration of A
in moles per liter, I'd say.
So C to the nu C power, D to the
nu D power, A to the nu A
power, and B to the nu
B power, in these
concentrations.
Where this ratio of logs comes
from expanding out the
chemical potential here.
And there's the log term here.
Just like an ideal gas.
Then at equilibrium, this is
equal to zero, you're at the
bottom of that curve.
And you set these two things
equal to each other.
And you get the chemical,
you get your equation
that you know well.
For the equilibrium constant.
And this time it's not K sub
p, it's just K. And that's
what you know from doing
solution equilibrium.
And it's just like V.
So the thing to remember, which
is the slightly more
advanced part, which you'll have
to worry about at some
point if you stay in some sort
of biochemistry oriented
field, is that you've got to
reference your initial
solution properly.
To get to the right equilibrium
constant.
OK, any questions?
Alright, then now we can do the
temperature dependence of
the equilibrium constant
in a general way.
Whether it be a gas
or a solution.
It doesn't matter.
It's going to be
the same thing.
So the question that we ask now
is, suppose that I change
the temperature of my
equilibrium, which way is the
equilibrium going to shift?
And you all know the answer
already, probably.
But let's derive it out.
So we're going to want to know
basically, we want to know
what is dKp/dT.
How does equilibrium constant,
or dK/dT, if you're doing
solution, how does the
equilibrium change with
temperature?
What's the slope?
Is it positive, negative?
If we have this, we can
integrate it out.
We can do an integral
over temperature.
And get an actual change.
So that's our goal.
To find how the equilibrium
constant changes with
temperature.
What do we know?
Well, we know how Kp depends
on temperature, through the
Gibbs free energy
of the reaction.
The Gibbs free energy, delta
G naught, has a temperature
dependence.
And then there's an RT sitting
on the bottom.
There's another temperature
dependence here.
Well, dKp/dT is sort of like,
we could also ask
what's d log Kp dT.
That might be an easier
question.
It's basically the
same question.
Especially since we have
something which is log K, is
equal to something.
So let's ask this question
instead.
Let's ask, what is
d log Kp dT?
Alright, so let's differentiate
both sides.
d/dT, d/dT here.
Got to use the chain rule now.
Because we've got temperature
as part of
delta G Write it out.
So let's take the derivative
with respect to the
temperature on the
bottom first.
We have delta G naught, which is
a function of temperature,
divided by RT squared.
The minus sign here disappears
when you take the derivative
on the bottom.
Minus one over RT, d/dT
of delta G naught.
So this is a derivative
of delta G, where zero
means here one bar.
Fixed at one bar.
So really, d/dT, with delta G
naught fixed on one bar, is
the same thing as the partial
derivative of delta G with
respect to temperature, keeping
p is equal to constant
at one bar.
It's the same thing, just
different notation.
And we know what this is.
In terms of other things that
we can find in books, like
delta H, or delta S. Because
we can go to
the fundamental equations.
To find out how delta G depends
on temperature.
And our goal is to get rid of
delta G, which clearly has a
nice temperature dependence
through the entropy term.
And to replace delta G with
delta H, if we can.
Because delta h is going to
be much less sensitive to
temperature and it's, delta H
is going to be over small
temperature ranges, is going
to be independent of
temperature.
And we know the temperature
dependence of delta H, because
it's through the heat
capacities.
So our goal is to get rid
of this delta G here.
And to try to replace it with
delta H, if at all possible.
So we go to the fundamental
equation for G, dG is equal to
minus S dT plus V dp.
And sitting right here is
dG/dT at constant p.
Which is what we have here.
So we get rid of this derivative
of G. And replace
it with S. So now, now we have
d log Kp dT, and I mentioned
already that I want to get rid
of G. Because it has a strong
temperature dependence.
And I want to somehow get H in
there, which is not going to
have a strong temperature
dependence.
And delta G naught, I can write
in terms of H and S, and
T. Delta H naught minus
T delta S naught
divided by RT squared.
And then my derivative here,
I have minus one over RT.
Partial of G with respect to
T. p is equal to one bar.
Well, that's just delta S. p
is equal to one bar, well,
that's just delta S naught.
Times delta S naught.
And that's great, because
now there's minus T
divided by RT squared.
That's one over RT.
And somewhere I've
lost a sign.
And there's my sign that
I lost, right there.
This minus sign here. d/dT of
delta G naught is minus S. It
actually includes this minus
sign right here.
Which is great, because now
things work out, because this
becomes a plus sign.
And this and this cancel out.
And this becomes delta H
naught over RT squared.
Great, so we have
what we want.
We have how the equilibrium
constant depends on
temperature in a way which
is very clear.
Where the top part is only
very weakly dependent on
temperature, usually.
And this is called the
van 't Hoff equation.
And this will tell us what
happens to equilibrium when we
change the temperature.
So if you want to do a finite
temperature change, now what
you need to do is, you
need to integrate.
You integrate both sides here.
From some T1 to T2.
From T1 to T2, and that tells
you, then, that the log of the
equilibrium constant at the new
temperature is equal to
the log of the equilibrium
constant of the old
temperature, T1, plus the
integral from T1 to T2 of
delta H over RT delta H naught,
over RT squared.
And this could be slightly
temperature dependent. dT.
And this is the integrated
van 't Hoff equation.
And if you're going to be
designing a chemical plant
where you have high temperatures
and high
pressures around, you
better use that.
Because there is some
temperature dependence in
delta H, through the heat
capacities of the reactants
and the products.
And that could make the
difference between your plant
running nice and smoothly
or your plant exploding.
And you don't want to have
exploding plants around.
So for heavy-duty uses of this
equation, you've got to do the
integral properly.
But for most normal
applications, like if you're
doing biology, where the
temperature changes by a few
degrees, like today I have
a little bit of a cold.
I don't have a fever, but
I could have a fever.
So my biochemistry would change
if I had a fever.
The equilibrium constant of all
my reactions would change
a little bit.
It's a small change
in temperature.
I'm not going to explode.
And so you can then take
the approximation.
In that case, the delta H
naught, is independent of T.
And this is fine over small
temperature ranges.
And that's the one that
you're most used to.
Is this approximation
here, this
approximate van 't Hoff equation.
Which is really fine for most
cases that you're going to be
dealing with.
So then, if that's the case then
you can take your delta
H. Ignore the temperature
dependence and take it outside
of the integral.
And now you can do the
integral fine.
And then you have an analytic
expression for the change in
the equilibrium constant
with temperature.
Log Kp at a new temperature, T2,
is log Kp temperature T1.
And I'm carrying this little
p around everywhere.
But really, it doesn't
have to be there.
This could be solution.
I shouldn't really have written
this for the specific
case of partial pressures.
But it's equally valid
for solutions.
Then we have delta H naught over
R. And then we have the
integral from T1 to T2, over
one of RT squared.
And if you do that the
right way, you get T2
minus T1 over T1 T2.
And that gives you the
approximate van 't Hoff equation.
Which is fine.
And you'll know that it's fine
in problem sets or exam,
because we'll say assume that
delta H is temperature - yes.
STUDENT: You said that
the [INAUDIBLE]
PROFESSOR: For K, if
K is solution K.
STUDENT: Right.
PROFESSOR: Yeah.
STUDENT: So then, can
you also use Kx?
PROFESSOR: Can you use Kx?
Well, as long as you keep the
pressure, the total pressure,
constant, then you should
be able to use Kx.
Let me think about this.
Yeah, here you would have p, you
have a log c so, you can
use Kx, fine.
Because then you would have log
p to the minus delta nu
times Kx, log p to the
delta nu minus Kx.
And the log of the
multiplication is
the sum of the logs.
And the logs will
just fall out.
So it could be any
K that you want.
Doesn't matter.
As long as you keep the
pressure constant.
If you change the pressure,
then you're in trouble.
So now we can see what happens
when you do change the
temperature.
If I have some equilibrium, and
it's all going to depend
on the sign of delta H. Whether
the reaction is
exothermic or endothermic.
And it's the same thing as Le
Chatelier's for pressure, or
Lenz's law.
The system doesn't want to
have change happening.
So if you have something that's,
delta H is less than
zero, it's exothermic.
Exothermic, that means that
it's putting out heat. it
wants to heat up its
environment.
And if I take temperature and
I raise the temperature, the
system's not going to
like that very much.
It doesn't want to get hotter,
and going from reactants to
products makes things hotter.
And if you go from products to
reactants, that's the opposite.
Go from reactants to products,
that becomes endothermic.
It sucks in heat.
You raise the temperature.
The system said no, no, no,
I'm happy where I am at my
original temperature.
I'm going to start sucking in
heat, to try to get the
temperature down.
And it's going to try to
make more product.
More reactants.
So, equilibrium K is going to go
down. and the reaction goes
towards the reactants.
And the opposite if you have
something that's endothermic
to begin with.
OK, delta H is positive here.
Delta H naught is positive.
You raise the temperature, delta
H naught is positive,
T2's bigger.
This is a positive number.
K becomes larger at higher
temperature.
K goes up.
The reaction goes to products.
So if you think of it in terms
of the system, the system is
at some temperature.
You raise the temperature.
System doesn't like it.
Says, I want to go back
to my original
temperature, what can I do.
I can try to suck in heat that
you're trying to put in the
environment.
That's great because if I make
more products, that's
endothermic.
And I'm just going to make more
products until I try to
lower my temperature.
So I move the equilibrium
to the products.
OK, Le Chatelier for
temperature.
Any questions?
On equilibrium.
OK, let's do a quick example.
Because this was the example
that we started out with,
talking about, the
Haber process.
This important industrial
reaction that started the
chemical industry,
essentially.
That uses up 1%, or close to
1%, of the world's energy.
If you think about it, that's
an amazing number.
1% of all energy
produced in the
world goes to one reaction.
One industrial reaction.
Just shows how important
it is.
OK, why does it take
so much energy?
We're going to find out.
We're going to find out why it
takes so much energy to run
this here reaction.
Alright, let's look at
this Haber process.
Take some nitrogen gas.
Plus some hydrogen gas.
And this is usually done over
catalysts, like an iron oxide
catalyst or something.
To try to speed it up.
It doesn't change the
thermodynamics.
As you know, and you'll hear
again in this class, catalysts
just affect the kinetics.
They don't change the
thermodynamics.
So this is usually done over
some catalyst to try to
speed things up.
To make ammonia.
And ammonia becomes the
feedstock for fertilizers, for
almost anything that contains
an amine in it, or
a nitrogen in it.
If you're going to make
proteins or whatever.
You've got to have ammonia
somewhere in the process.
OK, delta H naught of the
reaction, we're given all
these numbers.
At 298 degrees Kelvin.
And they're in your notes, so
I'm not going to go through
them in detail.
Delta G naught for
the reaction,
we're given that number.
At 298 degrees Kelvin, that's
minus 16, roughly minus 16
kilojoules per mole.
And we want to know, what is
the equilibrium constant.
Room temperature.
So you know how to
calculate that.
Minus RT log Kp, log K
is equal to minus RT.
Minus delta G naught over RT.
So you put that in there.
You get Kp is equal to 860.
A number, no units.
It's a big number.
It's a big number, you've
got the products
divided by the reactants.
It means that the products
are favored.
This is great.
What a wonderful reaction.
Shouldn't take energy to for
us to do that, right?
It's a room temperature
reaction.
Thermodynamics is great.
But even over a catalyst, this
is a really, really, really
slow reaction.
We'd still be waiting here for
Mr. Haber to produce his first
mole of amine, if you were doing
it, or ammonia if we
were doing it at room
temperature.
It's just so slow.
Thus, not at all practical.
We're not going to run the
world on room temperature
Haber process.
But it turns out, if you raise
the temperature, kinetics is
wonderful in terms of the
temperature dependence.
It's exponential.
Arrhenius rate law.
Great thing, you raise the
temperature by a little bit.
Rates speed up, things
go faster.
So if you were to raise the
temperature from 298 degrees
Kelvin to 800 degrees Kelvin,
the rate speeds up.
You're going to need
some energy.
As input here, to feed that.
Hence the 1% energy use.
Rate speeds up, that's great.
Things happen faster.
It becomes practical.
But, what happens if you
raise the temperature?
Let's see.
This is an endothermic, or
exothermic, negative sign.
And negative sign's
exothermic.
I raise the temperature,
K goes down.
I know how to calculate
it here.
And if I want to be super
careful, because it's a fairly
large temperature range, I can
even use the exact form of the
van 't Hoff equation.
And what I find, if I do that,
and putting the heat
capacities for all these
gases, I find
that Kp does go down.
In fact, it goes down
quite a bit.
It becomes 0.0007.
Two zero's.
Still really small.
That's not practical.
Not practical at all.
No good.
We can't run an industrial plant
with this kind of yield.
There's just no way it's
going to work.
So, you're a chemical
engineer.
Or a chemist, like Haber
and Bosch were.
And you're trying, you know by
Le Chatelier, you know that it
went in the wrong direction
for you here.
And then you look at your
reaction and you say, how many
moles of reactants do I have?
3/2 plus 1/2, that's two
moles of reactants.
And I've got one mole
of product.
Two moles reactants, one
mole of product.
Two moles reactant...
What happens if I change
the pressure?
If I change the pressure, if I
increase the pressure, the
system is going to say,
no, I don't want
the pressure increased.
It's going to go to where
there's less moles.
And the less moles in
the product area.
It's going to go
to my product.
That's great.
I've got to increase
the pressure.
Wonderful.
Let's start increasing
the pressure.
Again, we need some
energy to do that.
We're going to go from one bar
to some higher pressure.
It's going to make our lives
more complicated.
The plant might explode now.
If the pressure's too high.
All sorts of problems going
to come into play.
But, let's do it.
Let's increase the pressure.
So, you increase the pressure
from one bar to 100 bar.
And you calculate Kx.
Which is really what you want.
So Kx, in this case here,
is equal to p times Kp.
Kp doesn't change.
Kp doesn't care what the
total pressure is.
It's Kx that cares.
At one bar, Kx is equal Kp.
Kx is p to the minus delta nu.
Number of moles of products
minus the number of reactants.
If I go from one bar to 100
bars, Kx goes from 0.007 to
100 times 0.007, which
is equal to 0.7.
That's a lot better.
Kx is the mole fraction
or the, of
products divided by reactants.
And if I go to p is equal to 300
bars, then Kx goes to 2.1.
three times 0.7.
This is great.
Now I'm really starting
to make good products.
But I've got to go to 300 bar.
I've got to go to 300 bar,
and 800 degrees Kelvin.
That is incredibly
energy-intensive.
But it works.
That's why Haber and Bosch
made this work.
And why Germany stayed in the
war longer than after 1916.
The first world war.
Ended in 1918.
Nobel Prizes.
Merck, Bayer, all these
german companies.
Because they figured how to do
this at high pressure and high
temperature.
Without blowing everything up.
OK.
Any questions?
Alright.
The last topic is, so far we've
seen equilibria where
you had things that
were well mixed.
equilibria of ideal gases.
Or in solutions, where your
solutes, your solute molecules
are mixing around.
And the entropy of mixing was
really super important.
Our curve, our going down for
delta G, was all because of
the entropy of mixing.
Now, suppose that I have a
heterogeneous mixture.
I've got some solids or some
pure liquids that are refusing
to share their environment.
And staying as pure materials.
So, for instance, if I have
a beaker with some solid
reactant on the bottom here.
And the products are
in solution.
How do I deal with
that equilibrium?
Well, you know the answer, but
let's just do it out again.
So we're going to have nu
A moles of A, of solid.
Not mixed in the solution.
Let's say we have multiple
phases here.
Nu B moles of B,
which is a gas.
Instead of a solution, let's
do a gas phase reaction.
Nu C moles of C, which
is a pure liquid.
And nu D moles of D,
which is a gas.
So these two gases can mix.
But the pure solid and the
pure liquid can't mix.
So let's think again, where
does the equilibrium
constant come from?
It comes from looking at this
delta G of the mixture and
letting it react a
little bit more.
And taking out these chemical
potentials for the species and
the mixture.
Expanding it out in terms of
log p or log concentration.
So we need to have
this delta G in.
Let's take epsilon equal
to one, to make our
life simpler here.
So now we have nu C
mu C of the pure.
The pure solid.
Plus nu D mu C of the gas.
Which is in the mixture.
Minus nu A mu A of the
pure liquid, minus nu
B mu B of the gas.
Which is in the mixture.
That's what this delta G is,
when we allow the reaction to
proceed for a little bit more.
We add a little bit of chemical
potentials from the products.
Subtract a little
bit of chemical
potential from the reactants.
And then we expand it out in
terms of the standard chemical
potentials for everything
being pure.
Entropy of mixing
comes in here.
Comes in here.
Delta G of mixing
comes in here.
And we end up with something
that looks like nu C mu C
naught, plus nu D mu D naught,
minus nu A mu A naught, minus
nu B mu B naught.
Plus RT log, and the only place
where we have these log
p's, or log concentration
coming in, is for those
species that were not pure.
And those are only these
two guys here.
The ones that are in
the gas phase.
D and B. So we end up with
partial pressure of D to the
nu D power.
Partial pressure of B,
to the nu B power.
The other two species
don't come in there.
Because they started
out as pure.
There's no mixing going on.
And there's no expansion
of the log for them.
And so now, when we look at the
Q for the reaction, the
reaction quotient, it
doesn't contain
any of the pure species.
It only contains those species
that are allowed to mix.
Those that are in the gas
phase or in solution.
And so K, then, for this
reaction only takes in those
products like D. Or reactants
like B, which
are in the gas phase.
The pure solids or pure
liquids don't come in.
They come in for
delta G naught.
There's delta G naught
sitting right here.
Delta G naught for
the reaction is
sitting right there.
So when you write your log K
is equal to minus delta G
naught over RT, the delta G
naught has everything in it.
The pure stuff, the solution
stuff, the gas phase stuff.
But the K only has the gas
phase and solution stuff.
Alright, any questions?
Good.
Next time we'll do an example.
And then we'll go on
phase transitions.